[Music]
hello everybody it is Peri back here
with another Collider exclusive
interview at the supper suite in Park
City we are closing out day one of our
Collider studio super strong with the
group behind Zola big congratulations to
you all I hope you all enjoyed that
screening at Echols cuz was loud he was
loud so were you in the audience yeah
I'm surprised I guess I was so locked in
so what I was watching that I couldn't
even see you guys so job well done
age I wanted to start with you here just
what was your first impression when
there was interest in your story to have
it adapted to film poetry music kind of
girl but and were you getting a whole
bunch of offers and was there something
about this particular take that may just
say this is the one yeah I was getting a
lot I took my time with it to do I was
also getting a lot of like random script
said to me and they would be like hey
put your zola touch on this and I'm like
no Zola coins on this do that yeah I
don't know what stood out to me the most
with this group of actually it wasn't
even this group it was just janessa yeah
I can understand that I was telling her
earlier that I thought you gave one of
the best screening intros that I've seen
at the festival yet just from the heart
and it really got me in the right vibe
to see this movie so I have a feeling
that we're gonna see more stories told
on Twitter or social media adapted to
film in the near future so for both of
you as co-writers on this movie what do
you think the key is to successfully
adapting a social media story to the
screen
well yeah you need a good writer I mean
this so it's it's all the source what
the source material is I'm sure that
since she wrote that and even maybe
before that other people had written
pieces but they hadn't struck a chord it
was it is an amazing piece I mean we are
only as strong as our material and
everything that is great about the movie
stems from its seed who is sitting right
next to me and I talked about a lot was
that you know black twitter has been
like a major culture Shh like shaper for
since Twitter was incepted a decade ago
and one of the things that blacks were
the first said about this story was that
it was the thought I see a lot of people
keep riding around saying that was
called hashtag the story but it wasn't
it was called hashtag the thought to see
and what we really liked about that is
that it put it in conversation with like
the beginnings of Western literature it
put it in conversation with Homer and I
think that for the story that we wanted
to tell in the way we wanted to adopt
this is that we didn't want to be above
our source material we wanted to look at
it as though it was above us so we were
looking at home or we were looking at
Jamaica Kincaid or Toni Morrison or Sam
Sam Delaney you know and so I think
that's where that's the energy the
genetics and I came to it from and we
took all of the imagination and care and
heart that we would put into a beloved
piece of literature that you read in
school into this beloved piece of
literature that we all read on our
phones you feel it when you watch the
movie so job well done in that respect
going down the line here
Taylor is reading that YouTube bumped
into each other was that but was that
before or before this was on your radar
at all as that would kind of got you in
for the audition janessa would after
testing janessa would have to verify
when she saw me it was on largemont
I'd go get him tiger I didn't see her
but she saw me but she says that I saw
her and I didn't see her she threw some
shade at me she because I I didn't see
her she thought like I was the character
she rolled her eyes at me and I was like
that's her pictures I was taking some
pictures of you because I
Ben we are casting director Kim Coleman
I was like there's this girl she's on a
show I don't know her name it that it's
her I know it's her I saw her I saw her
move it that is how she engages in her
body is how I imagined Zola and and we I
couldn't I guess describe it well enough
for her for her to know who she was and
then I saw her and I was like oh it's
her that's the girl but when we're like
do you remember when that was it would
have been in 2017 yeah it was 2017 at
some point probably over this summer and
I took these secret pictures of her and
she didn't notice me taking the picture
but then she did look back at me and she
rolled her eyes at me and I was like it
is definitely dark please personally and
in my head it was there I feel like if
most people caught someone else that
they didn't know taking photos yeah what
is it yeah I think in this case it was
meant to be though so our souls were
getting closer and closer
that was our inception so you get the
script what are some of the biggest
questions that you have for Jeanette so
as far as getting into the role because
you want to do Asia story just assured
you're playing a real person but you
know is there any of you that comes
through that role as well and any of you
that is kind of shaped it to be your own
yes I think um I was working on finding
the balance of I wanted to go bigger and
this was very I was the straight person
I was the brain and I wanted to like
maybe pump it up and Jay Nix is like no
and I had I mean it was like a silent
film character yeah and I think that I
remember I was reminding you earlier
that when we first started working on
our second day of working Riley Keough
is not with us who plays Stephanie
pneumonia uh she has pneumonia it's
playing a very larger-than-life
character and Taylor turned to me and
she's like am i doing it wrong because
in reality like my personality your
personality like sometimes we are
subdued and then we code-switch we pump
it up we when I'm among my peers and
what I'm a you know it you're
there's that yeah
so we adapters divers is the way that I
spend a lot of time in whitespace and
when we're not in whitespace we behave
or engage differently and I remember
saying to you I was like you know you
are the straight man it is sort of a
more silent factor you are a watcher
because the way the angle at which she
wrote the story it was someone who was
watching it unfold right and the way
trauma is processed is also with this
sort of like distance of like that is
over there and I am over here and that
is how I can take the next step in my
own life to heal through this yes yeah
does that significantly change your prep
process as an actor jumping in as an
observer versus someone delivering more
dialogue like that yeah but I think I I
found it of it I just found the
confidence in taking the beats and
listening and actually ended up saying
so much more like I'm I'm speed well
there's like voiceover but I'm speed I'm
thinking you know like like I'm trying
to think of like something that wasn't
said but it's like I didn't say it but
I'm thinking it Whoopi Goldberg yeah
okay have you seen it yet I have seen it
so like I'm like rolling my body in a
man's face like doing this dance and
he's like you look just like Whoopi
Goldberg and it's like [ __ ] I'll cut
you but I don't say that you know what
I'm thinking a lot of that it feels a
little bit like Derrick could be you
know buddies with cousin Craig did you
get late did you get any like similar
vibes between the two of them cuz I feel
like watching the movie I could see the
two of them play off of each other quite
well huh
I don't think you I think they're I
think they're really different at least
I want I think they are yeah I mean
Derek is has no ambition
so like great let's make movies he wants
to make movies but he won't do anything
he'll never record himself making a vine
he'll never actually take the steps to
make his life better so he's stuck in a
really toxic diseased relationship like
a really awful thing and he doesn't take
the steps to get himself better
he just indulges in it more and more not
you not to talk about Greg much but but
Greg has ambition and has I think like
an intellect that Derek doesn't really
possess Derek's all emotions he's all
heart you know so he's so he can get
taken to a super high or taken to a
super low because he doesn't have a real
Center other than just his heart and
what will feel good right now he just
wants to be soothed right now okay the
posture a bit yeah yeah yeah definitely
there's a hunch - Derek that's pretty
special I think he looks at his phone on
so he's got that kind of neck thing that
happens when you're like this
exactly yeah no me too yeah but posture
wise I think so for sure can you tell me
a little bit about playing X and
specifically in terms of his presence
for some reason every single time he's
in the middle of a scene I feel like my
eye is drawn to him he's commanding the
room so can you tell me about
approaching the role like that well yeah
I think that's a lot that what was
written on the on the page that he's
very much someone who has got to be in
this centre it's got a it's trying he's
trying to operate and let this work for
him in every single way he's it's the
way he's found agency which is doing you
know which is in sex trafficking and
kidnapping and things like that in some
way shape or form
but I think that you know he's finding
his way and I but I think that he's he's
feeling like he's got to keep control of
it in some way
every element of it is spinning out of
control constantly and he's trying to
just keep some order in some way shape
or form but everyone has come into this
this weekend adventure with different
things on their mind and and it just
spirals can you guys tell me a little
bit about what shooting in Tampa brought
to the film because it's got so much
atmosphere in such texture and I feel
like you probably couldn't get it the
same way anywhere else but right there
on location there was a lot of make
America great again blue lives matter
energy help me out guys
it was motel rooms with bullet bullets
in the wall likes blood same hotel I
think a few people got fleas at it too
some of our crew I slept in a bed that
had a bug and left tampo special and I
think it's very much a character in in
our world and I was really happy that we
got to shoot there we had before getting
to shoot in Tampa explored or considered
other locations and once I actually went
I drove myself there I was shooting in
Georgia and I drove myself there as a
kind of like pitch to my producers of
why it was necessary and I met with this
location scout and we spent three days
going all around Tampa I had never been
to a strip club I went to 22 strip clubs
in three days and I see how much money
did you spend zero dollars
I was always scouting and it's a really
curious thing to scout while a strip
club is open because people start to you
know your energy feels different because
you're with somebody else and then
you're like can I take a picture and
then people look to the left and you
kind of take a photo and no one wants
you there in that way but it was yeah I
thought yeah yeah I think the big thing
was for me was the light actually our
movie does take place in a lot of
interior space
but the light in Florida is pretty wild
and something that was essential or
necessary to kind of inject into the
movie and I hope that it's there is that
I found that Florida during the day and
the night were sort of equally
terrifying to me like the Sun at its
highest had a kind of violence and when
it set there was that violence was still
there and or that aggression or that
pointedness and I and I felt like we
really needed to put ourselves in that
environment so that we felt it we'd
never have to look around and ask does
it feel like Tampa it just is also the
weather like I love that moment that
moment where she's in her yellow bikini
on the patio but it looks like a storm
has just come in and that just would
happen like the storm would just come in
out of five minutes color correction by
the way sometimes it's sunny and
sometimes it is shots of her face I
gotta let you guys go sadly thank you
again huge congratulations a big thanks
to everybody out there watching this
video do not leave it without liking and
sharing it and other big thanks to
Keough here at the supper suite in Park
City thank you so much for letting these
interviews happen we'll see you soon
with more content from the festival